this is a shapes I'll just watch as he  will get you miss Maria and then step  back Doc Rivers said it was the most  difficult cut that he ever had to make  Vardhan cuts right through the jazz with  another three how him to score now  anytime that you're a frontcourt player  you're gonna keep moving and you're  gonna keep running slow dance out here  James Harden choosing the music a little  bump to it seem like this is just  beautiful right here I'm right on yeah I  pardon just allows you to sleep with the  dribbling and now you see there it is I  get you to see the step back as soon as  Mitch harden gets into the paint and  crowded territory turns it over and  Gordon makes the steal at the other end  why not says harden and another three